illegal fireworks on the fourth of july
cost a man his home thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casa as the fire broke out
near russell and spencer and neighbors
we spoke to said there were a lot of
illegal fireworks in the air jeremy j
ford is live this afternoon with some of
those neighbors concerns jeremy
now guys if you look behind me what
you'll see is this brown home what
happened on the fourth of july at around
10 o'clock p.m illegal fireworks were
shot into the air and then came down
landing on the roof igniting the
shingles
that's concerning because you know if
it's a block away
imagine the houses who do not have
a fire station that's up in close
proximity neighbors we spoke to say in
this situation it was a good thing there
were firefighters close by they were
able to respond quickly and put the fire
out but the homeowner did lose a lot
in this neighborhood there are concerns
of potentially bigger issues so that's
that's a comforting feeling that there's
a fire station somebody's going to
respond as quick as possible when
there's a fire but uh i'm concerned if
it's a firework issue that's something
that has to be addressed
you know and something that has to be
enforced if it's caused by an illegal
firearm
now earlier today i spoke with a friend
of this homeowner who told me that he's
lost everything and as of now he's
looking for a new place to stay and he
even can't find his cat
jeremy j ford live local now